I think the Chinese government is
realizing that the economy is
overheating so I think they will take
proactive steps to slow down the last
quarter understand the growths are
running at rates of 12% of your GDP and
twos I think the Chinese government is
seriously considering whether they
should firm the Chinese currency because
of international pressure but also
because the economy is heating up too
much in terms of flows through exports
one is very obviously we
I'll tell you it's got to fix its
problem of the fiscal deficit that's
getting out of control - I think the
American consumer must learn to live
within his or her means you cannot have
a society where you spend more than you
earn I mean it's just fundamentally not
viable in the long run I think the
corrective steps which are taking place
now should lead in the right direction I
think one is that the India the American
consumer is learning to save why the
saving that you are running negative now
are running between four and five
percent and so far the fiscal deficit is
concerned I think the president and his
team are addressing issues which are
economic to see to it that they come
under more contain fiscal deficit and
the president is making tough decisions
which is why he is getting unpopular
with some of the commercial leadership